hey this is John Delaney in part three
of probably the greatest trilogy of all
time
my three-part interview with the one and
only mr. Anthony O'Neill so we've talked
about what you learned about yourself
you have to go back and watch other
shows if you want to know the answer
that's like the teaser number two
talking about what are you gonna do
right now
to carve your path on what the future is
going to look like right and here's
number three is you work with
Millennials you work with their parents
you've got eight hundred fifty trillion
followers on all of the socials you're a
church leader that's internationally
known well question would you have for
somebody with a PhD in counseling hmm
PhD I like to just put that out there
man you know one thing that I've learned
about myself and I'm hearing is from
other singles as well is that we are
identifying that single people are
selfish with us being like I mean we're
gonna be real oh sure you said be real
so with us being selfish is is that a
red flag for us should we is there
something off in our brains that we
should be fixing you know moving forward
well you said two heavy things oh shoot
think number one I don't like the I
don't like equating people to machines
people are breaking down or you need to
let off some steam those are all
references to factories right okay
people are way more complicated than
that and so when you tell me as a single
person you're feeling selfish what I
need to fix I would say a where you want
to go and be I don't think you're broken
because you choose to focus on yourself
if you choose to not be lonely then
you're gonna have to choose to be less
selfish you're gonna have to shift our
priorities right so going back to have
you been watching the last dance
I have MJ yeah so man I've got heavy
that last episode
talked about here's what the cost of
being remembered forever is and so I
would ask you that what's the cost of
selfishness for you mm-hmm that's so
good you've got a successful you're I
mean you're killing it you got you own a
home you got cars plural you got family
that loves you
you got church it like what's the cost
what would you back out of that thing to
say I want someone else's perspective on
my life I want someone else to be in my
home I want to share what we're gonna
I'm gonna have for dinner with somebody
else I'm gonna share where I'll go on
vacation with somebody else I want to
share goals with somebody else you want
me to answer that question you don't
have to how about its ya chicken I need
some time to think on that one brother
that was a deep question that's dads I'm
saying that's what I ask a single person
about selfishness because I think we
selfishness can can look like a million
for things to million different people
like if I tell my wife I want to have
tacos tonight I'm not being selfish or
mind just putting my preferences out
there in our relationship we've given
each other mission to say what we want
for dinner right so that's not selfish
all right if I throw a temper tantrum
and say we eatin tacos or nobody's
eating in my house that's selfish that's
me acting like a baby
right right right and so I'm not broken
I'm just acting like an idiot
right and so I'd ask you how is
selfishness manifesting himself out in
the world see what I did I just look the
whole thing right dad flip it on me so I
got to ask you a question don't flip it
on me
I'll superpower so what does selfishness
look like for you when it's all about me
you know one of the reasons why I'm so
single which is something I am working
on is I want to do what I want to do
when I want to do it without explaining
why I'm doing it and when I'm doing it
so I'm gonna work on that because it's
like I can't do that being married are
you married yes happily married yes got
kids okay you can't do that to your wife
BAE I'm going for two weeks good but I
don't want those things that you just
said I kind of want to do things all by
myself when I want to do it like I like
sharing that but yeah I've been single
for years
okay so I've I've established that
inside of me as a single person okay so
I want to change I want to get out of it
so I can make
room for a family okay but I know that
is something that I have to admit that I
have to start working on now before God
introduces me to my wife should we tell
the secret about changing those type of
behaviors
go for it sure yeah god I'd do them with
other people come here you can't do it
myself I love it and so instead of
waiting until all that stuff is fixed
before you hope God want to do somebody
to you since you're on the show this is
the big secret this is the big reveal no
Lord somebody out there you see him it's
gonna happen right now it's good hey man
let's do it yeah the big secret is you
change your heart and your mind and your
behavior your soul with other people and
so you won't be unselfish and then meet
the right person you'll meet the right
person and together yellow fuse all
right all right them they don't glad you
roll my show I'm sure
thanks for I feel our being away so I
get kind of emotional you know on my
show we laugh and have a good time so
I'm like this is John de Loney my good
for antionio check him out on all the
socials and they'll be right there all
right there or maybe over there and um
check out the two articles below stay
with us and next time we'll be wearing
different clothes it's good to see you
thank you for coming man man thanks for
have to a guess